[Music]
so let's say that you have
a cobweb problem in your house yeah
and let's say that um you don't really
have anything to do like anything to fix
that problem yeah a lighter except for a
blow torch a lighter not a blowtorch
well this guy only had a blowtorch oh
[ __ ] and he's like damn he burned his
house down that was stupid yeah he
burned his house down
the cobweb was like
that's just flammable you know that's
just like a wick to a [ __ ]
grenade what the [ __ ] because a lighter
actually works just like that
well he's a he's killing himself but not
if you're blowing if not if you're
burning what's behind the spiderweb he
doesn't have a vacuum
that works it doesn't say if he
can either confirm or deny they didn't
ask him
yeah bro that's how long the article is
it's four sentences it's not very long
he burned his own house down trying to
clear cobwebs with a blowtorch how many
[ __ ] cobwebs does this guy have in
his [ __ ] house he said it was a mess
later like i bet you
out of one like out of one of us we do
some [ __ ] there's some guy [ __ ] like if
you think about like
when
don't [ __ ] just throw it on me like
that that's a very broad umbrella
[Laughter]
for no reason dude
you telling me you never [ __ ] up
what's a guy accident because you were
curious
this is what happens it's it's it's
curiosity kills the man not the cat nope
nope curiosity burns your house down
i think we're modified we're motivated
by curiosity and fun that gets us into
some [ __ ] up situations man i think
you forgot the part of uh idiocracy has
to also be a part of the equation
but you never would read about a chick
burning her [ __ ] house down i always
kill my spider
you might to kill a spider it's never
gonna happen
dude they got to be a little creative
for the house you never suck some cords
into the vacuum jesus oh yeah suck some
court yeah because like the lady waited
the lady way would be like okay i'm
gonna vacuum right let me lift up the
cord and but guys are like [ __ ] it let
me try oh wow
yeah it'll come back out
[ __ ] six chords stuck in there it's a
challenge yeah that was a challenge or
do you vacuum like a woman is that why
well it's called a robot vacuum mm-hmm
did they do the work for you all their
[ __ ] i'm talking about gender roles we
all do the same stuff nah i don't
believe it
send this video to your girlfriends if
you get your dick sucked
i will i don't think girls want to take
that one because you know they'll be
like yeah we gotta be more like man and
i'm like nah you do not want to be more
like men you want to burn your house
this is men right here we'll [ __ ]
burn our house down because we're
curious about what this flamethrower
will do to a cobweb that's the true
testimony if you if you say you're like
hey i know i'm a man in in inside i'm
like okay but do you vacuum an area rug
because if you do then yeah yeah you're
you're on the team for sure i did some
man [ __ ] the other day dude like yo i
was like you know i'm vacuuming and i
was like yo there's a lot of dust and
[ __ ] on my yoga mat i might as well
vacuum that [ __ ] too and i just put it
on high power and that [ __ ] got stuck
and now i got a [ __ ] big ass like
vacuum burn mark on my on my yoga mat
yeah once you pick up the area i get i'm
like why don't you shut the [ __ ] up
[ __ ] business you know why because i
don't want to lean down and pick it up
who here gets rid of cobbles with fire
though
uh colorado man dude
if i was in a garage i mean how does it
take to have cowboys a while right that
means that food isn't clean clean at all
it depends on how much i hate the spider
that's true because if i really hate it
i'm gonna go ham you want to see a burn
yeah yeah spiders are pretty good for
the household as long as you eat your
legs i leave them alone because they eat
mosquitoes yeah i leave those in general
eat bugs in your house you know same
with like centipedes the things that
like make you feel all weird are the
ones that actually eat the other bugs
that piss you off centipedes like eat
other bugs like that yeah
i don't want centipedes these are not
[ __ ] no centipedes bro cause
centipedes don't bite your ass
centipedes look like they'll crawl on
your ear and [ __ ] eat your brain dude
yeah that's not an alien movie you know
yeah exactly i'm not [ __ ] around with
that [ __ ] all i'm saying is they eat
other bugs as well i'm just saying the
conversation you started
like [ __ ] you anthony
guy wants to take care of centipedes
yeah what the [ __ ] is that bro check
your check your roomba and see how many
centipedes are there i want to go to
anthony's house and see his bug
collection
uh this one's name is alfred uh he's
friends with jared he's like i heard you
guys are having a special on terrariums
he's friends with jerry mariams are
tight though yeah magnifying glasses
i did used to have magnifying glasses to
burn bugs yeah that's that's not that's
horrible man that's [ __ ] up
oh yeah that's so bad don't do that
speaking for a friend actually
one of us the one of us have any of us
gone hunting before no mainly i want to
go man i mean fishing's hunting right
i've been fishing
i've been a lot of fun all my life there
are different categories that's like
water water hunting it's water hunting
thank you water hunting dude it's way
too good i grew up fishing
you know why i think it's all like it's
not you don't grow up um inland like
when you grow up on a coast everyone
just goes fishing like i don't i barely
know people that went honey
but then like everyone that grew up like
i don't know like minnesota's that's
like you're supposed to fish oh even in
dna dude that's true we went fishing me
and uh gail one time and there was a
japanese guy on the boat charter boat he
was catching all the fish every time he
would throw his [ __ ] uh his uh line
out he would catch the biggest fish did
he even use bait no i want to hear yeah
that's what i want to hear that's the
real sometimes he would just go like
this
i think he just takes out his japanese
earwax
yeah dude
japanese earwax what's the stereotype
around that i don't know it's not very
pungent and it makes it
eat it it's like
i never heard that one before but it's
[ __ ] made out of miso soup
i'll accept it now it's [ __ ] miso
soup man that sounds so different it's
just natto coming back
that's where mata is from that's where
joe gets harvested steve relate to
anything in the last minute
oh dude you guys always think something
is an asian thing i'm like dude white
people fish all the [ __ ] times
the reason
my whole life it's actually annoying
how much white people say somebody's ear
wax miso soup bro dude my brother has an
earwax clogging problem so like the idea
i won't say which one but
[Laughter]
so it's you know
i probably shouldn't have said that
that's fine
that's a lot of personal [ __ ] you just
took like cylinders of earwax out of his
ear and then he would like be like i can
hear again and [ __ ] that's crazy how
often does he have to do that like every
six months so he's probably on one of
those like tick-tock videos it just
keeps growing but this is our videos are
wild wow
like the pimple ones you probably got
the wet ear wax that's why huh i don't
know dude but it comes out there's two
kinds depending on your genetics you
have dried all the earwax you have dry
or you have uh
i remember one time bart was thinking he
was going deaf and then he pulled out
earwax it was [ __ ] massive that's my
bro it looked like a [ __ ] musket
round oh the packed black ball like i
was in we're in hawaii i think you know
when you're like you're like snorkeling
and then someone's water gets in and
like kind of clogs it up and i think for
like half the trip i'm like [ __ ] i can't
[ __ ] hear [ __ ] it was like really
annoying me so i got one of those
squeeze ball things and i was in the
sink and you blast the water in and then
it kind of like loosens and it comes
back out and when it came out it was
like like this big like at least the
house you take a picture of it
no
it didn't it didn't smell very good
either i could watch i could watch
videos of that [ __ ] i love that
build up like that well i got dry ass
earwax i never had any balls come out
like that it's just like
flaky so this guy he's he uh he's
getting charges for arson all right
because for his own house was the
accident it was his mom's house oh so
yeah yeah this guy sucks he definitely
burned his mom's house down his mom's
house oh that means the mom charged his
ass if this really is a guy i don't
think he was even trying to burn cobwebs
i think he was chasing a spider with a
blowtorch it just like torched all his
body it was the cobwebs mom trust me he
was chasing his mom with the blow torch
you know what it is it's like that movie
arachnophobia doesn't he burn his whole
house down this is this is my favorite
part is that it's the movie where all
the spiders attack this guy's house and
then he sets his whole house on fire i
can guess the premise but what movie is
this it's called arachnophobia you never
heard of that i never said hey aren't
you are you an actor and like a film guy
only kind of creature movie i watch is
anaconda those are great that's the
second movie
the second one huh that's your favorite
snake on the plane too great movie but i
still don't believe anthony doesn't make
guy mistakes you don't make guy mistakes
what's what else is a guy mistake cause
he's judging okay what about this what
about this
does let's say you're driving right and
then there's like trash cans out you
know people who pull trash cans out on
the street and stuff do you eat out of
them do you
do you guys [ __ ] when you're when you
need to
leave the parking space
do you do a gentle love tap to know
where the trash can is or do you stop
before the trash can like a female
would you like him to say that ask the
whole question one more time yeah yeah
what the [ __ ] just happened visual
question i have to visualize one i don't
even have a driveway with a trash can
a lot of guy guy dude drivers they they
utilize the bumper the bump how many
times i hate my trash cans i have my
trash cans really yeah dude i just don't
do that you don't up bump there it is i
don't have a driveway with trash cans my
wife does the same thing too
yeah
different story but yeah i don't know
how to relate to this man i'm trying to
be a guy here or it's like you ever fly
your on your helicopter landing pad kind
of miss it a little bit did you ever use
your macbook as that [ __ ] coaster
or what he's like you ever aim with your
50 cal and just hit people
no do you ever take her open the door
and you open it as hard as you can you
bump it to the cargo oh there it is and
then you come out
there's the car bart's like you ever get
actually get into your third car but
then you're like wait i was trying to
get my first car
that's guy [ __ ] guy [ __ ] bro
oh wait i'm trying to get my first one
yeah what the [ __ ] this isn't my first
car it's my third car
[ __ ] careful boys guys [ __ ] boys guys
guys [ __ ] boys at the boys still yeah
guys guys [ __ ] balls with some guy [ __ ]
so this is my favorite part of this
article which literally is three
sentences what else is there to read a
ralph's ad no check this out so he was
under the house right to clear the
cobwebs oh he was burning in the house
in a crawl space yeah so he's like dude
this is gonna be a [ __ ] i'm gonna
[ __ ] just torch him out right go to
the wood foundation so he didn't want to
ask for help or get any help right so
then he then he exactly i got lighter
fluid instead he lights the house on
fire and then he says it and then it
says he tried to put out the fire for an
hour by himself before calling for help
stupid [ __ ] that's guys
what do you do pull the whole garden
holes out
i don't know it just says he was trying
to put out the fire for an hour by
himself ice cubes from the fridge
it doesn't work
slowly he's putting him in a shirt i
just love the moment of thinking like
all i'm gonna do is go like that cobwebs
are gone and then he goes like that and
he's like oh [ __ ] son of a [ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
you